président russe vladimir poutine vient
d'annoncer mettre en alerte la force de
dissuasion de l'armée russe une force
qui peut comprendre une composante
nucléaire annonce faite au quatrième
jour de l'invasion du crâne par moscou
une déclaration retransmise lors d'un
entretien avec ses chefs militaires à la
télévision marc perelman cette fois la
menace est brandie que prépare vladimir
poutine et qui peut l'arrêter et à
moscou alors c'est vrai que la menace
avait souvent dans des déclarations de
vladimir poutine il ya quelques jours
qu'ils avaient d'affirmer surtout que
l'ouest ne nous empêche pas de faire ce
qu'on doit faire l'ouest l'occident
c'est à dire l'europe et les états unis
là cette fois cette prise de parole
formelle devant ses chefs militaires
ordonnant la mise en alerte sa force de
dissuasion force de dissuasion c'est
bien nucléaire dont on parle alors
évidemment c'est juste une mise en
alerte on n'est pas à la veille de la
guerre nucléaire mais ces termes c'est
une escalade et il ya quelques minutes
dans un programme de télévision
américaine l'ambassadrice américaine aux
nations unies a affirmé que c'était une
escalade totalement inacceptable donc c
est une volonté de vladimir poutine de
faire monter la tension il affirme que
c'est en réaction à des déclarations des
leaders de l'otan c'est sans doute
évidemment en réaction à toutes les
sanctions qui sont en train de le
frapper de le frapper de plus en plus
dur - de plus en plus durement au
portefeuille et notamment aussi on a
entendu le chancelier allemand olaf
scholz ferrain un discours que certains
qualifient d'historique en affirmant que
l'allemagne allait dépenser beaucoup
plus pour son armée en annonçant de
l'aide à l'ukraine donc c'est vrai que
vladimir poutine veut réagir parce qu'il
voit bien que ce qu'il espérait se
passait en ukraine sur le terrain tout
d'abord mais aussi diplomatiquement les
choses ne se passent pas la façon dont
il espérait l'occident est très uni les
sanctions sont durs sont lourdes elles
vont frapper
l'effort est quand même assez vite et
donc c'est vrai qu'il lui reste une
chose en effet c'est l'arsenal nucléaire
la russie la première puissance
nucléaire mondiale on a peut-être
occupés aux oubliés pardon tous et
contre on faisait dans les années de
guerre froide mais la russie compte
d'après un institut spécialisé plus de
6000 têtes nucléaires les états unis
5800 tous les autres pays sont
évidemment loin derrière la france et
autour de 2 300 évidemment ce n'est pas
le nombre d'armes nucléaires qui compte
le simple fait de l'avoir évidemment
mais c'est vrai que c'est sans doute une
façon pour vladimir poutine de faire
monter la pression pas forcément parce
qu'il a envie d'une confrontation
militaire mais sans doute parce qu'il
est en difficulté et qu'il tente de
montrer qu'il ne va pas baisser les yeux
alors finalement l'ukraine confiante des
pourparlers avec moscou et à la
frontière ukraino bélarus biélorusse sur
quoi peuvent porter les négociations
alors déjà c'est vrai que c'est une
information pratiquement simultanée un
prouve que
les choses ne sont pas aussi simples que
quand vadim poutine affirme qu'il veut
mettre en alerte s'est parlé de
dissuasion nucléaire en même temps il
autorise évidemment c'est pour parler
éventuel alors jusqu'à il ya quelques
minutes les pourparlers en territoire
biélorusse avait été refusée
catégoriquement par vladimir zelensky en
affirmant que le bélarus étant un pays
qui dorénavant obéit à la russie et dont
gay qui sert de base pour des attaques
qui sont en train de se produire c'était
pour lui impensable d'aller à minsk donc
l'aîné les discussions se sont quand
même poursuivi et la présidence
ukrainienne a annoncé il ya quelques
minutes qu'il y aurait bien des
pourparlers à la frontière entre
l'ukraine et la biélorussie suite à une
discussion et ça c'est quand même
intéressant d'un point de vue
diplomatique entre volodymyr zelensky et
alexandre loukachenko le président de la
biélorussie
on peut imaginer quand même que si ces
pourparlers ont bien lieu parce que la
situation sur le terrain est tellement
mouvante que ça pourrait ne pas se
dérouler venir ce qui ne sera sans doute
pas
partie des délégations parce que dans
son entourage des gens avec qui j'ai
échangé on se méfie évidemment
terriblement de l'idée d'aller en
biélorussie et peut-être de d'être
arrêté voire pire donc on peut imaginer
que les ukrainiens vont être prudent
mais en tout cas
ll je rajoute juste que la présidence
ukrainienne affirme que ce cd
discussions sans préconditions donc il
ya quand même une possibilité ne
serait-ce que ténue de dialogue toutes
les portes ne sont pas fermées mais
évidemment tout peut évidemment déraper
très vite parce que la situation sur le
terrain avec des batailles un petit peu
partout est encore extrêmement volatile
il ya de nouveau eu un rassemblement ce
après midi à moscou contre la guerre et
contre poutine est-ce qu'on peut
percevoir d'après vous l'existence d'une
opposition à la guerre en russie y
compris même en dehors des
manifestations qui ont fait ça sont très
difficiles en russie et écoutez c'est
vrai que c'est la question que tout le
monde se pose parce que on sait que du
point de vue de l'information c'est très
verrouillé officiellement en russie que
c'est une sorte d'opération de maintien
de l'ordre mais évidemment plus le temps
passe plus des questions se posent y
compris en russie et c'est vrai que dès
qu'il ya des manifestations elles sont
étouffées dans l'oeuf mais on a vu
certaines personnes y compris dans le
monde culturel dans le monde sportif qui
souvent vivent à l'étranger me qui était
favorable à poutine et qui ont pris
position contre scène qu'est ce qu'elle
ait réussi son courant de toutes les
annulations des événements sportifs par
exemple je pense qu'ils vont finir par
l'être parce que on ne peut plus tout
contrôle et oui on veut contrôler les
réseaux sociaux mais les gens finissent
par savoir et c'est vrai que il y a
quand même une question de légitimité
pour vladimir poutine oui c'est vrai la
verticale du pouvoir il verrouille tout
mais six si ça dure s'il y a des morts
visiblement il y en a et si l'offensive
ne se passe pas comme prévu ce qui est
déjà le cas alors il faut relativiser on
est quand même qu'au bout de quatre
jours
ce n'est pas non plus que c'est un échec
on peut tout de suite proclamé mais
c'est vrai qu'il espérait sans doute
décapité entre guillemets le pouvoir que
volodymyr zelensky prendre le premier
avion pour les états unis et l'europe
occidentale ça ne s'est pas produit ça
c'est sûr et donc c'est vrai que plus ça
dure plus les respecte commençait ce
poids là un flux plus ils vont se poser
des questions plus ils voudront
peut-être oser l'exprimer
évidemment ce qui compte pour l'avenir
poutine c'est que le tout sa hiérarchie
militaire soit fermement derrière lui
mais attention c'est vrai que
on parle souvent d'une russie forte mais
elle a sans doute quand même les pieds
d'argile aussi parce que économiquement
et on va sans doute le voir la semaine
prochaine ce n'est pas la chine loin de
là le pib de la russie est équivalent à
celui de la corée du sud c'est tout à
fait respectable mais on ne parle quand
même pas d'une super puissance
économique c'est pour ça que ces
sanctions doivent beaucoup quand même
éveillé des craintes dans l'entourage de
vladimir poutine parmi les élites
politiques mais aussi les élites
économiques qui si elles sont frappés au
portefeuille vont peut-être se poser des
questions sur la direction que prendra
zimmer poutine merci beaucoup marc
perelman pour notre décryptage merci à
vous qui